Trascrizione: Eleonora Fantinel
Revisore: Giorgia Borsellino
Civitas e urbs:
le uniche due parole latine che dico,
quindi molto semplice.
Civitas, cittadini, noi tutti.
Noi tutti non solo oggi, noi tutti sempre.
Noi tutti, la cittadinanza
che voleva costruire la propria città,
il proprio spazio, le proprie idee.
Urbs, la città fisica.
I muri, le piazze, le strade, i tetti.
La cittadinanza ha sempre cercato
di rappresentarsi nella propria città,
nelle epoche, adattandola
alle proprie esigenze
con un modello, un modello ideale
difficile da raggiungere
nonostante il buon governo
che vedete sotto.
Quindi la città vera
è una città mossa, un po’ rotta,
spesso era una città, diciamo, sporca.
Era una città fatta,
molto spesso, per muovere,
e può essere una chiave di lettura,
le persone, le merci, l’energia.
Quindi abbiamo una città dell’asino,
l’asino che doveva trasportare.
E per trasportare,
per far passare un asino,
la città poteva essere piccola,
stretta, medievale.
Una città, come dire,
che interveniva poco fisicamente
ma non tanto per un’ideologia,
ma perché c’era poca energia,
pochi mezzi, poca forza.
La città piano piano prende altre forme
ma costruisce su se stessa
queste forme, si allarga un po’.
È la città del cavallo,
è la città dove le merci si muovono
più velocemente, anche un po’ meglio.
Iniziano a diventare città
più internazionali,
città che assumono la forma
della cittadinanza che le sta vivendo.
La città diventa la città della carrozza,
la città barocca, una città ariosa.
Il nuovo mezzo permette di avere
forme più lunghe da percorrere
che non quelle a piedi,
e diventano un po’ più grandi
ma sempre trasformando
profondamente sé stessa.
Cioè la città che noi abbiamo davanti
è frutto fino a un certo punto
di demolizioni, ricostruzioni,
trasformazioni anche violente.
Mura demolite per fare viali,
torri medievali demolite
per fare i palazzi rinascimentali.
Il nuovo mezzo: l’automobile.
La nuova idea di rappresentazione
della città, di sé stessa,
inizia a costruirsi fuori,
cioè abbandoniamo la città,
ma costruiamo qualcosa accanto,
che inizia a essere poco città,
che ha qualcosa della città ma che
non ha tutti gli elementi che danno forza.
Perché? Perché da lontano
con l’auto siamo liberi,
ci arriviamo velocemente
nel famoso centro storico
che ci dà ancora i servizi,
che ci dà ancora l’emozione.
E la città si dilata e perde questa idea
di ricostruire sempre sé stessa.
E poi arriviamo alla città di oggi,
della rete, della interconnessione,
dell’avere tutto a disposizione,
ma anche del barbecue.
Cioè dell’idea di stare in un giardino,
chiusi in sé stessi,
e vivere questa città disponibile,
disponibile in modo virtuale.
E allora diventa più che civitas e urbs,
civitas versus, contro la città.
Se ci pensate,
negli ultimi 60, 70, 80 anni,
la città l’abbiamo quasi abbandonata.
Parliamo di abbandono dei centri storici,
di ripopolare i centri storici.
Abbiamo costruito delle robe intorno
e questo ci ha spaventato.
All’inizio gli addetti ai lavori
che hanno visto il territorio
ridursi a una frammentazione costante.
E poi c’è una reazione
quando ci si spaventa
e la reazione è stata: “beh,
intanto difendiamo il centro storico”.
Cioè intanto dobbiamo, come dire, tutelare
e questo ha fatto passare dei messaggi.
L’azione è di per sé positiva, tutelare,
ma abbiamo iniziato a perdere
l’idea di trasformare.
Quindi ci siamo concentrati
su due mondi separati.
È la prima volta che c’è questa frattura
nella storia delle città.
Ripeto, le città si costruivano
sempre su sé stesse,
poi si ingrandivano un pochino
e si ritrasformavano.
Da un certo punto
abbiamo fatto una cesura netta.
Il centro storico che inizia
ad entrare nel nostro linguaggio:
la periferia, il centro storico,
il periferico, rigenerare le periferie.
È passato un po’ di, come dire,
l’idea che c’è una parte bella
in senso assoluto,
come se fosse sempre stata lì,
come se fosse stata costruita tutta con
un'idea e non trasformata continuamente.
E poi c’è una parte invece
nuova, brutta, da trasformare,
e allora sono passate delle idee,
ma sono passate anche delle leggi
che proviamo ad analizzare
in questo velocissimo percorso.
Cioè, se io modulo le città
che noi amiamo con le leggi vigenti,
le città che noi amiamo non ci sarebbero.
Per esempio, noi non possiamo costruire
fino a 300 metri da un fiume.
E quindi non avremmo il Lungarno,
non avremo il Lungotevere,
cioè questa città l’abbiamo già-
ne abbiamo già tolto un pezzo.
Poi parliamo di storico,
nella percezione che noi abbiamo,
con l’idea di vecchio,
con l’idea di “c’è da tanto tempo”.
Questa è la via che arriva
a Ponte Vecchio, per esempio,
penso una delle più
fotografate del mondo.
Tutti pensiamo che sia storica,
ma in realtà quei palazzi,
come vedete anche a un occhio
non decisamente tecnico
sono edifici in cemento armato
costruiti negli anni ’60
per la ricostruzione.
E se li guardate così adesso,
come li mette in mostra una foto di Google
non sono bellissimi, ma non lo diciamo,
sono abbastanza banalotti,
non sono questa gran meraviglia, ma quando
siamo trasportati dentro la città, dici:
“sto andando a Ponte vecchio, sono nel
Rinascimento, questa cosa è bellissima”.
Conserviamo tutto,
ma la città che noi adoriamo,
Firenze, Venezia, Roma, Parigi,
non ha conservato quasi niente.
Questo è il teatro romano,
è stato demolito
e sono state costruite sopra delle case.
Forse era meglio avere ancora
il teatro romano, può essere,
Quando si trasforma,
chi fa sbaglia, è difficile.
Oppure pensiamo di avere tanti monumenti
“no perché bellissima questa città”
ma poi se li guardiamo e li isoliamo,
sono dei bei palazzi questi
ma vi garantisco che anche tecnicamente
sono abbastanza fattibili,
è il tutto che dà forza.
Pasolini in un lungometraggio geniale
degli anni ’60 si poneva questi problemi
che si chiama: “La forma della città”.
Diceva: “voi difendete i monumenti,
io inizierò a difendere
le relazioni che ci sono,
i legami tra gli edifici,
le forme del vuoto”.
Perché è il vuoto della città
che fa città, non è l’edificio in sé.
I monumenti sono molto pochi
e molto poco diffusi,
molto meno di quello che si pensa.
Oppure sono entrate in noi idee:
la cementificazione.
Questa è cementificazione,
cioè si costruisce da sempre la città
al posto di boschi, al posto di crinali.
Noi siamo sopra un crinale,
dove oggi non potremmo costruire,
quindi anche Siena non è messa benissimo,
a livello normativo è abusiva.
Allora stiamo perdendo un po’ questo “no,
ma dev’essere tipico dev’essere del luogo”
Siamo partiti dagli etruschi,
abbiamo fatto i romani, il medioevo,
il rinascimento, io lo stile del luogo
non riesco a capirlo molto
farei fatica a descriverlo.
Questa è Piazza della Repubblica,
potremmo prendere qualunque altra piazza,
c’è un edificio sabaudo in fondo
e tutti facciamo foto a questa piazza,
pensando di essere
nel Rinascimento fiorentino
ma questo è un edificio piemontese,
è la forma di Firenze.
Sotto quell’arco c’erano
delle torri medievali.
Ci sono i palazzi rinascimentali,
cioè Palazzo Strozzi,
sono state demolite le torri medievali
per fare la Firenze rinascimentale.
Ma allora sono importanti materiali!
Ma guardate che l’architettura è fatta
con tre o quattro materiali sempre.
L’architettura è fatta di intonaco qualche
pietra qualche mattone e poco altro.
Non ci sono grandi materiali
nell’architettura.
Gli Uffizi di Firenze sono
un po’ di pietra serena, pietra sbagliata,
inadatta a stare all’esterno,
infatti si rompe.
Veniva usata dai medici perché
avevano meno soldi di quel che si pensa.
Un po’ di intonaco e qualche infisso,
peraltro postumo perché non c’era il vetro
Nel Rinascimento le finestre
non c’erano, erano telate.
Allora questa città l’abbiamo costruita,
gli vogliamo bene ci rappresentiamo ancora
siamo contro o pensiamo
di cementificare e abbiamo paura?
Ma perché abbiamo paura?
Abbiamo paura perché
piano piano ce n’è sempre meno di città,
ci abbiamo levato tutte le regole
che la costruivano.
Nulla, l’aspetto esteriore,
ci sono mille stili nell’architettura
non ce n’è uno migliore di un altro,
ma l’idea proprio di città l’abbiamo persa
ci siamo spaventati,
abbiamo levato l’altezza, abbiamo levato
il volume, abbiamo levato la dimensione.
Questo ci è rimasto.
Oggi stiamo nel 90% dei casi:
da un lato diciamo che il centro storico
è fondamentale, è bellissimo
ma le regole con cui
lo abbiamo costruito le neghiamo
nello stesso momento che costruiamo
un pezzo nuovo di città.
Nessuno si senta offeso
perché molti di noi vivono in abitazioni,
in villette, e non c’è niente di male
ovviamente del cittadino.
Io parlo proprio dell’idea
di rappresentarsi nella città.
Allora quando leviamo volume,
la città diventa bassa ma l’architettura
con 3 metri di altezza non si fa.
Ci siamo dentro un’architettura alta,
potremmo dire una speculazione edilizia.
I materiali sono quelli,
sono quelli degli Uffizi.
Ce n'è anche un po di più
in questi quartieri.
C’è qualche pietra in più, c’è sempre
l’intonaco, c’è sempre coppi e tegole,
non è che c’è grandi materiali,
non ci sono agli Uffizi e non ci sono qui.
Lo spazio pubblico si è perso,
gli edifici da soli non reggono.
Se voi vi immaginate
l’edificio che preferite,
non so, il Battistero di Firenze,
la Chiesa- il Duomo di Siena,
e lo mettete in un prato da solo,
vi garantisco che non funziona.
Le relazioni funzionano.
Io penso che la riflessione
che dobbiamo fare
è proprio quella di ritrovare il coraggio
di aggredire in modo positivo,
guardando al passato, le nostre città,
innovandole, trasformandole
e recuperandole,
ma non aver paura di metterci le mani.
Chiudo:
due cose personali perché quando ho saputo
che ero qui mi sono venuti dei ricordi.
Un mio professore a cui era molto legato
è scomparso prematuramente,
abitava qui vicino, e mi diceva sempre
“Davide, i progetti criticali
con progetti migliori.
Cioè fai anche un po’ vedere che sai fare.
Inutile dire questo è brutto questo bello”
Quindi questo è un mio progetto
lo faccio vedere per levare l’idea
che sia storicista contro modernista.
Cerco, provo, ragiono sulle relazioni.
Qui c’è un archetipo storico, il teatro.
È un teatro fatto alla vecchia cava
quindi è cementificato
perché la pietra è stata presa, ma sotto
c’è il cemento sennò non stava in piedi.
Quindi una cementificazione. C’è
qualche materiale nuovo, c’è qualche idea,
c’è l’idea fondamentale che
chi ha criticato quest’opera
inteso come analizzato,
è stato un po’ vista in giro,
E la più bella analisi l’ha fatta una
signora che all’inaugurazione ascoltavo.
Non mi ricordo il nome, ma la citerei
volentieri e disse all’amica:
“No, ma questo c’era, l’architetto
l’ha scavata e l’ha tirato fuori”.
E lì c’è però tanto,
al di là della mia soddisfazione,
nel luogo c’è l’architettura.
Cerchiamola, c’è la città, proviamola,
analizziamola ma non abbiamo paura.
Quindi secondo me la priorità che mi
è stata chiesta è avere coraggio
e rimetterci in discussione,
non scappare dal centro storico
perché le città non nascono
storiche, nascono nuove.
Poi possono diventare vecchie,
le abbiamo fatte male,
o storiche, le abbiamo fatte bene.
Grazie.
(Applausi)